Are we just saying that I'm beginning
to recognize some of you people.
I would ideally like to have a class with
maybe just 10 students so that we can
have a lot of dialog and I can find
out what you're thinking about,
address your questions, that'll
make a lot of fun. But you know,
that's not possible in
an introductory course,
but I think you should feel free to
interrupt or ask questions or discuss any
reasonably related issue
that I didn't get to. Okay.
That would make it interesting
for everybody because I
told him many times the
subject is not new to me. It's
probably, it's new to you.
So what makes it interesting for me is
the fact that it's a different class with
a different set of people with
different questions. And Trust me, uh,
your ability to surprise me is
limitless because even on the subject,
which I thought is
firmly fixed in my mind,
some of you guys come up at some point
of view or some question that always of
interest to me or for people who have
been practicing this business for a long
time. So I welcome that. And
that'll make it more lightly.
All right,
so I think last time I got off on a
rant about all the different pedagogical
techniques,
some of which I don't endorse fully.
I'm going to go back now 300 years in
time to one of the greatest laws that we
have. Because look at the power of
this wall right here is the equation
and all the mechanical phenomena that we
see around the world can be understood
with this law.
And I was starting to give you examples
on how to put this lot of work because I
think I at least made you realize that
simply writing down the law does not give
me a good feeling for
how you actually use it.
So maybe you have understood it,
but I'm going to remind you one more time
on how you're supposed to use this law.
So I'm going to take a concrete example.
The use of any law of physics is to
be able to predict something about the
future given something
of what the present.
So all problems that we solve
can be categorized that way.
So I'm going to take a very simple
problem problem to which I will return in
great detail later on. But
let me first start with, uh,
let me start with this problem,
which I will do very quickly now and we'll
come back and do it more slowly later.
But at least it's a country problem.
The problem looks like this.
So here is a table and here's the spring,
here's some ass m there's
a forest constant, a,
I want to pull it by some amount of force
constant k I want to pull it by some
on capital a and let it go.
So that's the knowledge of the
present question is when I let it go,
what's this guy going to do?
That's the typical physics problem.
It can get more than a more complex.
You can replace the mass by planet.
You can replace the spring by the sun,
which attracting the planet,
you can put many planets.
We can make it more and more complicated,
but they all boiled out
a similar situation.
I know some information now and I want
to be able to say what will happen next.
So he had to pulled the mass.
When I'm on a and I want
to know what it'll do next.
Remember when we go back to the loss of
Newton laws of Newton only tell you this
and we've been talking about
is this useful information?
First thing you have to know in
order to use the laws of Newton,
you have to separately,
no, the left hand side,
you have to know what force is going to
act on a body. You cannot simply say, oh,
I know the force of the body.
It does anytime say m a is
not a force acting on a body,
it's the response to it force.
You gotta have some other means of finding
the force and in this case the force
on the masters due to the spring.
So I pull the spring by various
amounts and I see what force it exerts.
No, I think you know now in practice
how I know what force it exerts, right?
I pull it by some amount attached to
say the one kilogram standard mass.
I see what acceleration of experiences
and m times that acceleration or one
times the acceleration is
the force the spring exerts.
So I pull it up by various amounts and I
study this spring and I have learned by
studying the spring that the force it
exerts is some number k called the force
constant times.
The amount by which I pull it,
if I start off the mass in a position
by the spring is neither expat or not
contracted. That's what we
like to call x equal to zero.
So I pulled it to x equal to a,
now what I'm told is when
you pull it to any point x,
that's the forest to spring exerts.
So this is part of an independent study.
People who work in spring physics,
we'll study springs.
They will find out from you,
find out and tell you when
anytime you buy a spring from me,
it'll exit this force and they have done,
they figured that out by
pulling the spring and
attaching it to various entities
and seeing what acceleration it produces.
They're the masters I've taken to be
known because you can always borrow the
mass from the bureau of standards.
Are we discussed last time?
How if you have an unknown mass,
you can then compare it to this
mass and find out what its value is.
So every objects mass can be measured.
And then the guys making the
spring have studied what it does,
do different masses and figured this out.
Now you come with this mass and you say,
what happens when I connected?
Well I'm assuming the mass of this guy
can also be found by comparisons the way
I described to you last time. So we
can always find the mass of any object.
We went into some length.
Then Newton's law says this is equal to
m a but I want to write a as the second
derivative of.
So you now go from a physical law,
but is really a postulate.
There is no way to derive f equals m a
you cannot just think about it and get
it. So whenever I do physics, I will
sometimes tell you this is a law.
That means don't even try to derive it.
Just summarizes everything we
know in terms of some new terms,
but it cannot be deduced.
On the other hand,
the fate of this mass can no be deduced
by applying Newton's law to this
equation. Now, this is a
new equation you men out.
I've seen this equation before.
For example, if I told you,
forget the lefthand side,
if it's totally the right hand side is
96 I think you guys know how to solve
that,
right?
You have to find a function
who is secondary [inaudible]
96 divided by m and you
all know how to do that.
It's t squared times a number and you
can fudge the numbers so it works.
This is more complicated.
The time delivered to have this
unknown function is not a given number,
but the unknown function itself. In other
words, x itself is a function of time.
This is called a differential equation.
A differential equation is an equation
that tells you something about an unknown
function in terms of its derivatives.
You can have a differential equation
in wall being the secondary way to the
first delivered to the 14th derivative,
whatever it is.
You're supposed to find out what
x of t is given this information.
So one thing is you can go to the
math department and say, hey look,
I got this equation. What's the
solution? And they will tell you now,
sometimes we have to do our own work and
we can solve this equation by guessing.
In fact, the only way to
solve a differential equation
is by guessing the answer.
There is no other way.
You can make a lot of guesses and every
time it works you'd be keep a little
table. Then you publish it called table
of integral. So I have in my office,
you'd huge table mark
capital's got his own integral.
We don't leave home without our table
of intake notes. I got one at home,
I got one at work.
I may want to keep one of the car because
you just don't know when you will need
an integral. Okay, so people have
tabulated them over hundreds of years,
but how do they find them?
They are going to find them in the way
I'm going to describe to you now you look
at the equation and
you guessed the answer.
Let's make our life simple by taking a
case where the force constant is just one.
Okay, takes one Newton per
meter to stretch that spring.
I let the mass of the
object we want kilogram.
This is just to keep the Algebra simple.
Later on you can put any M and K and
we'll do all that. Then what am I saying?
I'm saying find me a function.
Who's second intervention
is minus that function.
Now as a word problem, maybe
it rings a bell, right?
Do you know such a function?
Uh,
explanation.
Yes.
Exponential is good. Another one,
yes. Trigonometry functions that good,
so I'm going to temporarily
dismissed the exponential.
I will tell you why an exponential
function is actually a very good guess.
You can say x equals e
to the t for example.
The trouble is this is growing
exponentially and we know
this spring mass system,
the x is not growing exponentially.
Or it might say,
well let me fix that by making it minus t.
Then it quickly comes to rest after the
time and doesn't move. We saw the field,
we want this thing to be jiggling
around for a long time, so
the exponential function is even better
than this function because it says take
one deliberative and they reproduce
myself, but that's too much.
We only want to function.
That reproduces itself when you take
two derivatives and that's where the
trigonometry functions come in.
So I make a guess XFT this core scientists
and you can check if you take two
derivatives,
it'll basically equation the secondary
available avexis minus x itself.
But do I like this solution or that
there's something not fully satisfactory?
Yes,
you kept up the negative when
you, pardon me, it's great.
Actually t squared is,
that would be negative yet.
Oh, it will be negative
x. So let's do that.
So let's take DXDT is equal to minus sine
t then take one more deliberative the
two x over Dt.
T square derivative of sine is cost side.
So this is minus cost sine t
but x was course scientist.
So it's really minus
of the excise started.
Yes.
So you had a question or
you wrote it up there.
Oh, this one? Yeah. Kotlon film. Yes.
That's a mistake.
Okay.
That should be minus very good.
Look,
it makes me mentally happy
when you guys catch me.
Of course it becomes an addiction. You try
to catch me. Sometimes it doesn't work,
but keep trying this time you
are absolutely right that way.
That's where you were looking confused.
Anything else?
Everyone followed the way this
very elementary problem is solved.
It's solved by making a guest. So
you're right. So the minus sign was one,
but now you agree everything is
working. This is the answer, but no,
I meant something else is not
quite okay with this. Yes.
Yeah.
That first of all I can add some sign
of TNL still work, but more importantly,
if I put t equal to zero
and you get x equal to one,
why should it be true that I
pulled it back exactly one meter?
I could have pulled it by
two or three at nine meters.
I want to be able to tell how much
I pulled it by a t equals zero.
Suppose it was pulled to five meters and
released. I want x of zero to be five.
The point is you can easily fix
that and putting a five here,
does it screw up everything?
It doesn't because the five just comes
along for the ride everywhere and don't
think it's five x because
this five is part of x.
So you can multiply your answer by any
number you like and you pick that number
which reproduces your
initial displacement.
So if you pulled it by five we put a
five so now we are very happy to describe
this problem. It is true. You can put
sign t but I will in this problem,
we don't need it. Here's an answer
that does everything you want it to do.
The initial time it gives you five Times
Square signed zero which is five and
that's what he told me was initial
displacement. Initial velocity.
If you take a DXDT is proportional,
the scientist and the t equals
zero that vanishes. That's correct.
You pull it and you let it go,
so the instant you released it,
it had no velocity and it satisfies
Newton's laws and that's your answer.
I want to do this simple example in
totality because this is the paradigm.
This is the example after which
everything else is model. Yes,
but me.
Ah,
you mean a t equal to zero. If the answer
was scientist, scientists vanishes,
the t equal to zero and of course it
doesn't manage has a robust value of one
but I want a value five.
I put a five in front look,
you guys may have a few more things to
say about this problem because this is
not the final and most general
solution to the problem.
It is a solution that certainly works
for the one example I had which is a mass
being pulled to five meters and released,
so carry this in your mind.
This is really to me the most important
thing I can tell you right now,
the way I fake,
what's Mas applied in real life is half
the world is working on the lefthand
side. Finding the forces that act
on bodies under various conditions.
In this example,
the force due to a spring and by playing
with the spring you can study the force
that exerts had various displacements
at various amounts by which you pull it
and in this example if you
pull the spring by an amount x,
it exerts a force minus Kx and you can
measure k and you put the label on your
product and you sell the
spring with a given k.
Other people are measuring masters a
various objects and they've decided the
massive, this is whatever,
maybe one kilogram.
You put the two sides together and you
find the response of the system for all
future times and what this tells you.
Then you can apply this.
This is a graph that looks like this
goes from five to minus five and repeats
itself and it's very nice.
That's what we think the spring would do.
Now you think this is a real spring got,
I'm missing something.
This is the whole story.
Yes,
it's friction because we know
if you pull a real spring,
it's not going to oscillate forever.
It's going to slowly stop shaking
and pretty much come to rest.
That just means who do you want
to blame for this equation?
Do we conclude now that something wrong
with Newton's laws or what's the problem?
Pardon me?
Uh, the fault is not with a k. Yes.
Taking the capital that is correct.
So we will say we have missed something
that's another force acting on this mass
besides the spring.
That's the force of friction that'll
oppose the motion of the mass.
So you can say one of two things.
Either you can say something is
wrong with Newton's laws are,
you can say we have not applied Newton's
laws properly because we haven't
identified all the forces.
So if you'd never knew about friction,
you do this and you find, hey, it
doesn't work. The mass comes to rest.
Where does the theory
says isolate forever.
So you are at a fork a that you
can say Newton philoso right.
I'm missing some forces. I'm going to
look around and find out what they are.
Then you will derive
friction from that art.
Maybe it's time to give up Newton's laws.
It turns out even if there is no friction,
this is not the correct law. Physics,
correct lies given by Einstein's
relativistic dynamics that this does not
satisfy the relativistic dynamics.
By that I mean if you really pull a real
mass by five meters or whatever it and
release it is,
motion will not be exactly what I said.
What would it be off by a very,
very,
very tiny amount that you probably
will not discover in most laboratories,
but if the mass begins to move
with velocity is comparable
to that of light than
this equation will be wrong. So people
say, oh, what kind of business are you in?
Every once in a while somebody is wrong.
I tell you right now,
everything we know is wrong. You know
it's no secret. You can publish it.
You can tell the whole world, this
practitioner said everything is wrong,
but it's wrong in this limited sense.
Is Newton right or wrong? Well,
Newton didn't try to describe things
moving at speeds, comparable delight.
You dealt with what problem he
could deal with at that time.
So it's a lot of that has it
limited domain of validity.
You can always push the
frontiers of observation.
Did you come to a situation where the law
doesn't work but the special theory of
relativity doesn't also work all the time.
If the mass becomes very tiny,
becomes off atomic dimension, then you
need the laws of quantum mechanics.
That's wrong too.
So things work in a certain domain and
sometimes you abandoned the formalism but
don't rush to do that.
In this case,
the problem is not with
formulas but due to friction.
So you have to make sure
you've got all the forces.
Once you got all the forces
is still doesn't work,
then of course the experimentalists are
very happy because there's something
wrong with the theory. Then you got to
find the new theory till that works.
Okay, so that's the cycle.
So it's an ongoing process.
Physics is still a work in progress.
This is work it a 300
years ago and no one's fun.
Anything wrong with Newton's
laws provided. You don't
violate two conditions.
You don't deal with objects moving at
speeds comparable to that of light and you
don't deal with the objects
which are very, very tiny.
The notion of watch video tiny will
be very clear when you learn quantum
mechanics. Next term, right now
that is something rough called tiny.
There's things like atomic dimensions.
All right,
so now we are going to do
more concrete problems,
but I wanted to write that up for you
as a simple solvable worked out example
that displays everything that
happens in physics. All right,
so by the way, people are always looking
for new forces, electrical forces.
You find the charge on a table,
it's not connected to a spring.
I bring another charge next to
it and this guy starts moving.
What do I do about the
accelerating without any force?
I can say Newton is wrong or I can say
maybe there's a new force between that
body and this body and that will
turn out to be the electrical force.
Electrical force occurs. Whenever
you take something, you know,
you take a cat and you take a
piece of amber are, you rub it,
you do various things,
then you put them next to other things
and they're attracted or repelled and you
discover you're charging things that, so
electricity with discovery, but you know,
you don't have to have a cat.
If you have a buffalo,
you can take it to the
buffalo still works.
Then you got to find out what you
really need to find electric forces.
But you find that it's a new force and
you know you've got a whole new forced to
study. Then you got to find out
what's the cost of the force turn.
Salary's not the mass of the object.
If something else called electric charge,
then how does the force
very, with distance, uh,
well it varies like one over r squared,
you know that.
So that's how you slowly
study and identify new forces.
So the forces were found in the order of
gravitation first and then electricity
and magnetism.
And now of course there are new forces
called strong forces that are weak forces.
They are acting the sub nuclear level.
So that's why that business is not done.
We are not finished with the left
hand side is looking for new forces.
Okay,
so now I'm going to start doing
problems in two dimensions.
Everything I did last time is one d.
You know you're pulling something,
you're pushing something, you got one
blog connected to the second block,
third block and you pull it.
We have done all that.
So we're going to elevate
this to higher dimensions.
And as you know in higher dimensions,
acceleration is a vector and so forced
better be a vector because when you take
a vector,
multiply it by a number,
you get something else and there by
that process you've gone to higher
dimensions.
So let's take again simple problems and
try to make the motor more complex and
you cannot tell me eventually you
agree the problem is complex enough.
I will crank it up as we go along.
Some point you plead for mercy,
then we'll stop.
But there is no limit to how
difficult mechanics problems can be.
If you go back and read
Cambridge University exams
in 1600 and 1700 they have a
really difficult problems.
That's why we invented quantum mechanics,
which is a lot easier than those
problems from Newtonian mechanics.
You can make it as hard as you like.
So I'm just going to do a few.
Then once you got the idea you stock, but
again, we're going to start with easy.
One easy one is a table on which this
master sitting doing absolutely nothing.
And we want to study that guy and
understand it in terms of Newton's laws
because we had in two dimensions
you gotta have two axes.
So here is my ex and hate us.
My why.
So the first rule is if ethic was m
a we are really saying I at times Fx,
let's DF times ef.
Why is m I x Plus N J
a y?
It's a vector equation.
The force has to be a combination of
my and j because nobody, by the way,
I'm working in the x y plane.
I told you I don't need to go to three
d for a long time in three every back.
Does someone want to buy in some
amount of j. That's what drew forever.
That's true for day. You write it out.
Then I told you have two vectors at equal.
Then the next components have to match
and the white parts also have to match.
You can see that if I draw two arrows on
the plane and I tell you this Arrow is
the same as that Arrow,
it's the same.
It's got the same horizontal
parked in the same vertical part.
So this is really two equations and
I'm going to play them to this block.
So when I look at this
block in the x direction,
it's not moving at all that are known.
Law enforces acting in the x direction
and that therefore is the case of zero
equals zero.
Did I miss something?
You guys look a little worried?
Yes.
Okay.
Okay. Now I look in the y direction.
If I look in the way that action,
I take this block and had rides
free body diagram, namely,
I write all the forces on it.
So that is the force of gravity.
M g wait, this. Sam is a
big game are smaller than,
Oh let's change the figure two small lamp
so that the rest of the equations are
right. The little mg is acting
down. If that's all you had,
the block would fall through the table.
It's not doing that to the table.
We know is exerting a force.
The Standard Name for that
is n and n Stanford. Normal.
Normal is a mathematical
for perpendicular.
You say this vector is normal to that
vector you mean they are perpendicular and
here we mean this force is
perpendicular to the table.
They had the forces in the y direction
in the y direction and is a positive
force with a plus sign mds,
a negative force and that's
equal to m times a. Why?
It's interesting that in this
application of the Newtonian equation,
I'm going to say that I
know the right hand side.
I know the right hand side is zero because
I know this block is neither sinking
into the table, not flying off
the table is sitting on the table.
It has no velocity.
It does no acceleration vertically.
So that has to be zero because I know
the right hand side is that Newton's laws
quite often either I will know the
leftover, I will know that right?
Either I will know the force that
I will know the acceleration.
So if this is zero,
I come to the conclusion and equal same g,
this very simple example,
but this is how have
you figured out why the,
how the Newton's laws work in
this particular problem. Okay,
now I'm ready to introduce another
force and that's the force of friction
as you all seem to be aware that his van,
really a force of friction between
this mass m and this table.
So how do we learn that is a force
of friction. Suppose someone said,
how do you know what that is?
Friction. Here's the mass.
What experiment will you
do that tells you, hey,
that is another force called
friction. Can anybody tell me? Yeah,
something you would do?
Yes.
Okay.
Okay. What's up? It's on this table, but
you are around. You can do what you want.
Yes,
go ahead.
Constant.
That's possible. That's good.
That's a very good answer.
One answer it is. You find that to
keep it moving at constant velocity,
you have to apply a force.
That means the 48 applying is canceled
by somebody else because that is zero
acceleration. That's
gotta be Zero Force. Yes.
Just apply force to personal day.
Everyone knows.
And that tells you that there
must be a force that's active.
Very good. I'd even before that,
even before it starts moving,
you find that if you push
it, it doesn't move. Right.
I tried to push the podium.
Well I don't know my own strength,
but I'm going to imagine I pushed it. It's
not moving. But if I push hard enough,
it will move. What's happening before
it moves? I'm applying a force.
I'm getting nothing in return for it.
So I know that is another force opposing
what I do and that's called the force
of static friction.
The static is when the body is not moving.
So I'm applying a force F uh,
let me give it some other name.
Little F. No, that's not so bad.
Little left was the name for friction.
So I'm going to play force calledF sub me.
You can label these things
anyway you like, okay,
this particular rotation that's not
caught on because people are not as
interested in what I think as I am, but
right now I'm going to call it f sub me.
I invite you to invent any notation
you want because there's nothing sacred
about rotation. At least I want
to convey to you that north.
So I call it f sub me,
I'm applying to the right.
Then I know that it's not moving that
forward. That has been other force,
that cancer suit. But how
much is the other force? Yes,
that's correct.
So it is not a fixed force.
Static friction is not a fixed force.
It's whatever it takes
to keep it from moving.
It will not be less than what
I applied because then remove.
It cannot be more than what our plight
because then we'll start moving backwards
so it will do what it takes
to keep it from moving.
So static friction is a force which
has a range from zero to some maximum.
So let's call it the force of friction
is less than or equal to some maximum.
Yeah.
And that maximum turns out to be a
number called the coefficient of static
friction times the normal force.
The force of friction seems to depend
on how much normal fourth the table is
exerting on the object,
which in our example, if you
want to do, in our example,
not always,
this is always true,
but in our example you made a place it
by new s times mg because Anders equal
AMG. So the force of friction seems
to depend on how heavy the object is,
the sitting on the table. But what does
it not depend on that it could depend on?
Can you think of something else?
Could depend on but doesn't. Yes.
The amount of surface area that seems
to have been depending on the area of
contact. In other words, if
this was a rectangular block,
it doesn't seem to matter whether it's
doing that or whether it's doing that.
You might think, hey, that's gotta be more
friction because there's more contact,
but it doesn't. So it's interesting.
Not only what it is, but what is not.
Okay. This is called the
corporate and status friction,
so I guess you guys should remember
that the force that friction applies is
equal to the force that I apply up to
a maximum of this and once I beat the
maximum, it'll give up and it'll
start moving. Once it starts moving,
you're going to have
a situation like this.
I apply episode me this way and friction
will apply a force which now is called
Musa Kinetic Times normal.
So the force of friction is different
when it's moving a Scott, by the way,
it is not moving is slightly
less once the body is in motion.
So it's always true for all situation.
Musa kinetic is less than Muse of static.
Okay, so this is how you categorize
friction. You study various objects,
then you find out friction certainly
depends on the nature of the two surfaces.
Given that constant,
it seems to depend only on the
normal force and not on the 18th
yes,
less than the maximum.
I remember we were sub candidate
is a fixed number, right?
Maybe point to Musa static as a fixed
number 0.25 if it's 0.25 for static it
means if the normal force to some mg
up to quarter of the weight is the
frictional force.
It can apply to preventives motion stop.
I say I play a force on a body which
is originally one 10th of its weight.
It won't move to 10 type its weight.
It won't move quarter of its weight.
It's a tight 0.26 situate him
start moving once it starts moving.
Frictional Force will
be 0.2 times its weight.
9.2 is because the kinetic
friction is less. This is,
yes. The summary of friction. Okay.
So far even though I used vectors,
most of the action is just in
one or the other direction.
Yes.
No, it against seems it can
actually depend on many things.
Friction is something we don't understand
fully but it depends only on the
normal force.
Just the way I described.
Okay.
Now we are going to do the one problem
that has sent more people away from
physics than anything else.
Do you know what it is?
You haven't heard about the
problem that sends people away?
Okay?
This is called the inclined plane.
A lot of people may not remember
where they were during the Kennedy
assassination, but they say, I remember
the day I saw the inclined plane.
That's the day I said I'm not going
into physics because this is very bad
publicity for our field.
You know,
you come into the subject
hearing volatility and quantum
mechanics and then art,
maybe gravitation and astrophysics.
And we hit you with this.
So why am I doing this?
Well,
if you can do this and you find it boring,
you can move on.
But if you couldn't do this,
you have no right to complain because this
is the entry ticket into the business.
You gotta be able to do this only then
I can tell you other things. Okay?
So we have to, we'll do this
quickly watching the clock.
I won't linger over this,
but we have to do this
problem. Okay? So let's,
let's quickly finish this problem.
So here is the problem that isn't
mass m sipping on the inclined plane.
It makes them angle here.
You want to know what it's gonna do?
All right,
we know it's going to slide down the hill.
What do you want to be more precise?
And the whole purpose of Newton's laws
is to quantify things for which you
already have an intuition.
So the only novel thing about inclined
plane is that for the first time we are
going to pick out x and y axes.
Not along the usual directions,
but along and perpendicular to the
implant. That's going to be my accent.
That's going to be my why.
And I ask what are the
forces on this mass?
Well, I've told you first
deal with contact forces.
The only thing in contact
with the mass is the plane.
The inclined plane can exert a force
in general along its own surface and
perpendicular to own surface.
But I'm going to take a case,
but there is no friction.
There's no friction by definition.
It cannot exert a force
along his own length.
So it can only exert a force in this
direction. And we're going to call that an
then there's only one other force. That's
the force of gravity, which we agreed.
We have to remember, even though
the earth is not touching this,
block it or to somewhere down here is able
to reach out and pull this block down.
So let me show you the forces.
So here is an,
and here it is mg,
study your forces and with no friction,
that's it.
That's the key to doing any
problem I give you in any exam,
no matter how stressful,
I guarantee you would get it from Newton's
laws provided you write every force
that is there and don't write any
force that is not there. So this is it.
You said the two forces and the mass will
do what these four says tell it to do.
So what we want to do then since
my access or in this direction,
I have to take this AMG and write
it as the sum of two vectors.
A one witness pointing in this direction
and one which is pointing in that
direction. So if I add
these two arrows, I get mg,
that's called resolving the forced
into some other directions. Now,
the key to all of this is
to know that this angle here
is the same as this angle here.
Other words,
if AMG is acting down,
that angle data is the same
as this angle data here.
This is going to be used all the time.
I'll tell you a little trick that tells
you how, how you figured that out.
Data is the angle between the
horizontal and the incline.
Now you've got to agree that if I draw a
perpendicular to the horizontal and the
draw perpendicular,
the incline angle between
those two perpendiculars
will be the same as the angle
between the two lines they began with
because perpendicular means rotate 90
rotate both lines by 90 the angle
between the rotator lines at the same,
the vertical is perpendicular to this
horizontal and this is the perpendicular
to the plane. Once you got
that, the rest is pretty easy.
So in the x direction I'm going to write
the following equation mg times sine
theta.
So you've got to understand that this
part here will be mg time scientists and
this part here will be empty
at times cause scientists,
you've got this something you'd better
get really used to it for vectors like
this and you want the force in that
direction, the angle, but fitness data.
Then you put the cost side,
the component that's adjacent to the
vector of course sign of the this one here
is a data. So I got the horizontal
part in the x direction.
I got MTA assigned data and that's it.
There's nothing else that's
gotta be equal to m times X.
Remember x is not horizontal.
A access along the inclined
downhill in the y direction.
I write n minus AMG consigned
data is m times a y.
That's simply writing down
Newton's laws as two laws,
one along x and one along why
and putting in whatever Reno.
What happens next is up to
what else we know, well,
we know that this block
is sliding down the hill.
It's not going into the block,
not as it flying out of the
block is moving along the plot.
That's the reason we chose the coordinate
to be perpendicular to the block
because that coordinate the
white coordinates not changing.
Even even though the block is sliding
down the hill when it's sliding down the
hill, the usual x and y coordinates,
if you define them this way,
they're all changing.
But by this clever choice is always at
y equal to zero. So he does know why.
Coordinators know why velocity
does know why acceleration.
So we know this guy is zero.
So this is an example of where we know
the acceleration by this kind of argument.
From that we did use that n
has to be mg cause scientists.
Okay then you come to
this fella here they had,
we found out that x you canceled the
m and defined as equal a g scientist.
So that's the big result.
It looks like down the hill with
an acceleration g signed data.
This is a good way to measure the g by
the way because if you drop something,
it falls too fast. What
do you do? Payment.
But if you let it go down an
incline by making data very small,
so it's is very in the gate, in the
very low, the body can accelerate, uh,
with a much slower acceleration downhill
because there's reduced by this factor
assigned data. Okay? Yes.
Another thing I should tell you right now,
most of us when we become professionals,
don't put the numbers till the very end.
So if you're told the [inaudible]
angle of 37 degrees, g is 9.8.
Don't start putting numbers into the
first equation. We don't do that.
And I know for some of
you it's pretty traumatic.
The work with symbols and
sometimes an exams, they say, Oh,
you had all these problems with symbols,
but I want to sell you another idea.
It's much better to work with
symbols then with numbers to Leanne,
why is that? First of all, if you put
numbers in and I suddenly tell you,
hey, I was wrong about the slope
is really 39 degrees and not 37,
you're going to do the
whole calculation again.
But this way you come to the formula
and you say, what's your data?
You changed your mind.
Okay, that's the new data.
You changed the value of g you
made a better, better measurement.
That's the answer. Then you can see if
your problem have some mistakes in it.
Suppose you've got g squared or scientist,
you will know it's wrong because this is
an acceleration. That's an acceleration.
Units have to match and signed it.
Of course there's no units.
Then maybe you got the trigonometry wrong.
Maybe it's really [inaudible].
That should be the right answer. How do
an old signed data? You can do a test.
We know for example, as the incline
becomes less and less inclined,
you've got to get less and
less acceleration because
it's going down hill less
and less and theater goes to small values.
X also diminishes
all right if you'll take your incline and
you really make it almost vertical and
in the end you make a completely vertical.
The block is just falling under gravity.
[inaudible] is 90 it becomes g
so you can test your results,
so be prepared for that part.
If you are in this course,
I will give you some homework problems
in which the numbers are not put into
liberty and that I may not even ask you
to put the numbers in because the thing
is to get this formula because anyone
can take the numbers and put them in the
calculator.
So that's going to be a part
of our agreement that we
will work with symbols and
if we look at any calculation we do,
if you caught me in my office,
I am not putting numbers in very early.
I mean I cannot wait to
find out what the answer is,
but I keep the symbols to end.
Then I put the numbers.
Then you can very different numbers. You
can say, what if the gravity was weaker?
I go up to Denver and do the experiment
but I get a different answer. You will.
So how things depend on the input
parameters is interesting. Yes.
Another interesting result.
What is missing in this formula
that could have been there?
I'd make the mass. It doesn't
seem to matter what the object is.
That's an interesting property
of the dissolved. Right?
And that's because m cancer load
of the two sides of that equation.
So these are all interesting features
you would not know if you kept numbers
everywhere and you get a equal to
0.62 meters per second square to meet.
That number doesn't tell me as much in
the end I want to know the number but the
formula is very interesting.
All right,
so now we're going to make
it a little more complicated.
We are going to now add friction to this.
So he hit us the block but now
does the Coefficient of friction.
Let's say the block is uh, let's
ask the polling. Simple question.
I think it was related to
what one of you guys said.
Let the blog be at rest and
data is an angle. I can vary.
Maybe that is a little thingy here.
You can turn it back and forth.
Let me crank up data and see when it
will start slipping. In other words,
there is a coefficient of static
friction between the block and the plane.
And I want to know like parking
your car in San Francisco.
What angle can it take before
it starts sliding down?
So let's write the forces and
let's write f equals I may.
So the forces are again right here.
Let me cut to the chase and Wright,
MD Cosa and data here and here.
AMG signed data here.
Watch la right for friction.
Do not write mu s times then because the
frictional force is anything you need
optimum us times. In other words, if
they had that was very small and empty,
signed data is very small, the frictional
force will be, in fact MD scientists.
It'll equal whatever it takes
to keep it from slipping.
But if I cranked up the angle to that
maximum angle beyond which it cannot stay
there,
let's give a name to that angle.
That is sine theta star
at the maximum angle.
Friction is doing the
maximum thing it can do.
Then we can certainly say mg sine theta
is then equal to the static friction
times n,
which is now mu s times mg coastline data.
Again,
the mass cancels,
so it doesn't matter what kind
of car you parked on the slope.
It only depends on the following.
G can some stew.
So where did you park your car in the
air at the park it on another planet.
This is going to be the same restriction,
which is that temp data
has to be less than or equal to us equal.
The US is the critical value.
Less than that is acceptable.
Okay?
That's a simple problem. If you tilt it
the more than that, it will topple over.
So now let's take another problem
where the block has started moving.
It's going down the hill. Now
what formula do way, right?
You notice that I'm not writing every
step, every time it's time I deal with it.
I'm going to do some things faster. But
example, I already dissolved gravity.
The two parts of it are going through
the whole song and dance because you know
how to do that.
Now I put in the friction.
So now make God a muse of Kennedy,
not equal equals zero mass is moving.
You can ask,
and I'll watch the acceleration now.
So the horizontal equation along
x is going to be AMG scientists.
Data minus mew candidate
times a normal force.
But allow me to write for the normal
force AMG course and data that's gotta be
equal to m times X.
No. Can you do this? That's the test.
This is not enough to watch
me do this and say, okay,
he seems to know what he's doing.
The question is, can you do this?
Would you have thought about this?
Do you agree that I'm not doing anything
beyond Newton's laws when I do this?
Yes. Each one of you should
ask, if you cannot do that,
you have to deal with that now because
this is only going to get component.
On the other hand,
if you can do this,
you know everything I
know about Newton's laws,
this is all that is to Newton's laws and
how to apply them. So you cancel the em.
So notice here,
this is the normal force,
but I've taken the why equation that
says normal force is MD codes and data.
Put that here.
Then I find acceleration is g Damon's
sine theta minus mew subcommittee.
Of course scientists.
Okay. Yeah, that's the result. A
X, this is what I'm calling a no.
I want to study this in Beatty has limits.
First limit I take is no
coefficient of kinetic friction.
I get back to my signed data.
Well, let me try the following.
Interesting limit.
I crank up the coffees and the kinetic
friction more and more and more.
Look what happens here.
Scientists and [inaudible] fixed numbers.
If this become larger than
some amount than say a 10 data,
what happens to the expression?
A is negative. And what does that
mean? Block is moving uphill hill.
Do you buy that? So what's wrong? I mean,
I took the equation right. I told you,
told you all the time. Have you can
study various limits. Something is wrong.
It says if kinetic friction is very
large block, we'll move up here.
Okay.
Uh, that's not the reason. Yes.
Oh,
uh,
oh, that's not the reason. Uh, why made
you can, you can also vary the angles.
Maybe keeping care of Sun Valley,
the angles so that this number of times
that can beat this, then what happens?
Yes.
You were already assigned the direction
downhill.
That is the point. Okay. Did let me repeat
his answer. That's the correct answer.
You're right. Board candidate being
less than static and so on, but are,
you can always imagine
keeping that number constant,
but changing the angle to the coast and
gets bigger in size and get smaller.
At some point,
the agree coastline will beat the site
because sign is going towards zero and
costs and going towards
one or the correct answer.
It is in writing this force law,
I'm assuming the force of friction
points to the left uphill.
That is correct only if the
body is moving downhill,
but if you've got an answer, but Ava's
negatives, definitely going up hill,
the starting premise is wrong,
so one videos for lesson to learn
here is when you apply a formula,
don't forget the conditions under
which you derive it and don't apply the
results to a case where the answer
does not belong to the domain that you
assumed you're applying it to.
The trouble with friction
is the following.
Friction is not a definite fours with
a definite magnitude art direction.
This magnitude is definite, but
direction is not definite. It is uphill.
If you're going downhill, it's down
nearly. If you're going up hill, okay?
It's like the constant
opposition to motion,
bad as force of gravity,
the normal force,
everything else is fixed that actually
you can try it once and for all.
So in a formula where the forces
are what they are in any context,
you can apply the formula in any limit.
But if the frictional force
assumed a downward motion,
don't apply it when the block is going on.
Okay?
So I'm going to do one more of
this inclined planes and then, uh,
pretty much done with inflamed play.
Okay?
This is the problem off to masses.
Uh,
that is a rope that goes over the pulley.
Let's call this little lamb that's called
that big game at this angle. Again,
stay down and no friction.
You can mix and match various things.
But let's keep friction out because I'm
planning to do something different here.
Okay?
So do we want to know what
these guys will do now?
So first guest is, well am looks, capital
m looks so impressive, competitive,
small am so maybe it'll go downhill if
I realize that of course fallacy because
capital Emma's a symbol,
the value associated with maybe
one 10th that was smaller,
but the big end really is bigger
than small and then am I short?
It'll go downhill.
Yeah.
Pardon me. Has to be
good though. No, no, no.
I'm saying the, the big mass m
is bigger than the small mass.
And is that enough to say
we'll go downhill? Yes.
Depends on the angle because part of the
mass is not helpful in going downhill.
See if I had a pulley like this,
then you want absolutely right.
Big Guy Wins.
Now it's not clear because uh,
this has got all of
gravity pulling it down.
This got only part of gravity pulling
it down. So let's skip this direction.
It's not very interesting.
Let's look at this direction for
risk equation is the following.
If I just took that block,
it's got AMG scientist acting down and
this rope will exert a certain tension t
here, which I don't know. Under
the combined effect of these two.
I can say mg scientific data is equal to,
I'm sorry,
minus t physical,
the m a but a is assumed to
be positive going down here.
That's one equation. Then I come
to this fellow here, this block,
well, it's got little AMG acting
down and tension acting up.
I'm sorry guys.
I made one mistake here.
I think you'll know what it is
or this should be capital am
I should be capital m
salary for that and capital
for small n the equation is t minus M g.
Now let's be careful with what I do next.
I'm going to say little m
times a which is the same a,
yeah,
you should all understand why the
acceleration in magnitude is the same.
We're not saying that
that action is the same.
This is accelerating downhill at some
angle. That's accelerating uphill.
These are not the questions
which are the vectors,
the Stanford Equations
along certain directions.
This is the up down direction here and
that is up to slope down the slope.
That action for that one. But I think
you realize if the rope is inelastic,
if this mass moves down one inch,
that's got to go up one inch.
Therefore if it goes one it in one second,
so when the other guy,
they will have the same velocity and
they'll have the same acceleration.
So that's why there's only
one unknown acceleration a.
Once you realize that you're done
because now we know what to do.
Whenever they see a minus 10 or plasty,
you add them and you get g times m sine
theta minus little m on this site is
going to be a big game plus small
m time say, can you see that?
So let me short circuit one step
and divide by began a smaller.
So that's the formula here
and again, you've got to ask,
does it make sense? Now if you
notice that for it to be positive,
namely to go down hill,
it's not enough.
A big gamblers bigger than smaller
began signed data should be bigger than
smaller.
That's because m sine theta is the part
that's really pulling down him m course
and data is trying to ram it into the
inclined plane and that's being countered
by the force.
Second thing to notice is can I use this
formula when big game and small limb is
bigger than big m's, St data. Other words,
can I use this formula
when it becomes a negative?
After all I did all my thinking
saying it's going down,
but can I use it when it's going up?
Yeah.
Yes, and the reason anybody want
to say why that is okay here.
Yes.
Pardon me. No friction, right? Great.
Change is of course that is correct.
All the forces I drew here,
they're not going to change their mind.
When you change the body's motion grabbed,
this all is going to pull down.
So all of these forces that fixed and
magnitude and direction and therefore once
you got a formula for positive way,
you can apply to negative way,
but you cannot do it when
you have friction because
in friction you assumed the
direction of motion.
All right,
so now I'm going to leave the plane.
This is it.
We had finished with a plane. Uh,
you are not finished because, ah,
don't clap yet because I got a
homework problem by popular demand.
Two masters,
one pulley and friction.
That's the really, say we're finished
with a plane. Once you can do that,
you graduated from this bootcamp,
you can handle anything else,
but that's not something
I want to do in class.
If something you do in
the privacy of your room,
put all these things in and crank it
up and you'll always have enough time.
But that's the video that's got
some interesting angles. Uh,
you should think about, okay,
so now I'm going to do, um,
physics that basically
involves a rotational motion,
but let me do one Mickey mouse problem
and let it go because they assigned it to
you. Typical problem is that is
a tree here. That's a tree here.
And that is that our two ropes and there's
some backpack hanging here with some
wheat.
Uh,
you are told what that angle is
in your total, what that angle is.
You're supposed to find the
tension on these two ropes.
I think it's fairly simple.
So I want to the details,
but you know what you're supposed to do.
You take these two tensions,
break them at a horizontal parts with
science and because science and into
vertical parts, how does Arthur parts
better to cancel? Because this mass,
this backpack is not going
any event horizontally.
The vertical parts of these two which
will be in fact additive should cancel the
weight of the object that gives you two
simultaneous equations for t one and t
two and you can fiddle
with them and solve them
well.
By the way,
I should tell you if you've
got some equation like t
one sine theta one equals d
two sine data to that minus t two st it
a zero and another equation involving t
one with some numbers and t to
some are you seem to have trouble the
other day when that resigned. Data's here.
Let us, if this had been
numbers like three and four,
you knew how to solve this
simultaneous equations,
but I want you to realize that the
solving of the simultaneous equation for t
one and t two involve farming combinations
of these coefficients to eliminate
either t one or t two
so when you add them,
one of them drops out and that doesn't
depend on whether these are two economic
functions or any other
numbers you eliminated in
the same way like race on the
right hand side instead of some numbers
like three and four you have the wait w
of this mass. Well if you
multiply this equation by three,
multiply everything by
three and juggle them.
So you should get used to
eliminating coefficients,
which are not simply numbers,
which are symbols, science, core
science, but you don't have to.
If you had a sign here and of course sign
there, for example, how will it come by?
And then maybe you will multiply this
by saying in that way a sign and if you
subtract, it'll drop out. You
got to do stuff like that. Okay?
But it's important in a level.
Physics 200 level course,
you'd be able to solve those things.
Okay,
now I'm coming to the interesting problems
in which motion involves going in a
circle.
So here's one problem.
This is a string on which there is a
mass and the mass is going around in a
circle. This is like an amusement
parks where they have these uh,
dangling little tiny baby rockets and you
sit there and start spinning and as to
being vertical, it starts lifting up.
You want to know why it's lifting up.
So if this angle here is data and this
is some mass m and is going around in a
circle with Velocity v and the radius
of the circle is a are you want to find
some relation between design,
we'll Taita and these other
parameters in the problem.
So what do I do? I apply
f equals Ma, that's it.
And I'm going to get everything by a
planning f equals I may to this guy.
So here's that mass.
The tension on the rope
can only be along the rope.
Rope is not rigid object. It cannot
exert a force perpendicular to itself.
It can only pull it along.
It's that action. That's
the tension on the road, uh,
that is mg
and that's it. Under these things,
it's going to obey f equals m a.
So what I do with this tension is I
trade this guy for two forces. This is t,
uh, if that angle is data, let
me see. That angle is data.
So this is t scientists and
this is tico scientists.
So you trade that oblique t four to
t or the actual simple directions.
The fact that it's not going up or down
vertically tells me mg on the t signed
data.
I'm sorry.
Yes.
Okay.
Then in the other direction,
t sine theta is the horizontal force.
That's got to be a mass times
acceleration at the incident.
But I've shown the object
because it's going in a circle.
It an acceleration in this direction
with Sites v squared over R.
Therefore, if you divide this
equation by that equation,
you want to get v squared
over r g equals stand data.
That's the angle that string we'll assume.
So if you knew the velocity,
you can do this problem.
Okay?
Then here's another interesting problem.
When you go on these roads,
you've got going in a circle,
stuff like this is your car.
I'm looking at you from the top.
You're going in a circle.
Anything wrong?
Yeah,
going in a circle,
you're accelerating towards the center.
Someone's got to provide the force.
That's what Newton says.
That forces the friction between
your tire and the road. In fact,
it's a case of static friction.
You might think as Kennedy
because the car is moving,
but it's not moving in this direction.
So it's a static friction
that keeps you from slipping.
So you need a certain static friction.
So that n times muse static at n equal
AMG must be equal to m v squared over r.
If you didn't have the static friction,
your card will not be able
to make the curve to fly off.
So what people have done is to find a
clever way in which you don't have to have
any friction. They can still make
the turn. That is the bank your road.
So imagine I'll get going into the
blackboard and you're turning left and the
road looks like this is going away from
me. No, I don't have to draw this thing.
This is the road is that track restaurant
going round and round like this and I
gave it some angle table.
This road has no friction so it
can only exert a force that way.
But let me resolve the
force into two parts.
One like this and one leg.
This again,
if these two have an angle Taito that
is the same angle data there and that is
the mass of the car this way.
Okay,
so what do I find?
I find an core sine theta equal to AMG
and [inaudible] signed data.
Okay.
Equals MV squared over R.
Okay,
that 40 if you again, take
the ratios, you will find 10
equals v squared over r.
G I think this may be a little fast now,
but you guys can do the Algebra.
What that means is the following.
If you want the car to go around
the bend at a certain speed,
40 miles per hour or so
many kilometers per hour,
and the road itself is part
of a circle of radius r.
It doesn't have to be full
circle at that instant.
It has to be a part of his circle.
Then if you bank your road at that angle,
you don't need any
friction to make the turn.
You got to understand how we
beat the system. If you wrote,
instead of being flat is tilted,
then even though the road can only
exert a frictional is normal force. Now,
part of the normal force is
pointing toward the center. In fact,
this picture is not
drawn to scale the druid.
That way this part of the vectors are
desirable and direct it towards the center
of the circle on which your orbit.
That's how you do the banking in any
good system of roads you'll find that is
banking.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to do the last problem because
it's in the homework and then maybe I'm
a little late today. I apologize for
that. The last problem is very famous.
Very important. That's the loop, the
loop problem. As you know, the loop,
the loop is when you come down on a track,
you go on a circle and for
a while you're upside down.
Okay?
And the famous question is, you know, why
don't you fall down? What's the trick?
Does it violate Newton's
laws? And so on. We'll find,
we can understand it
fully with Newton's laws,
but we'll find out that in order
for this thing to pull it off,
it's been at that instant,
has to have a minimum value.
And the application of Newton's
laws to this object is very simple.
It is gravity.
What about the track on which is going?
What's the direction of the
force that track exerts?
Pardon me down.
Anybody set up attract,
cannot exert a force upwards down.
So everybody track aimed yet
all acting downs. You see,
that's when you get a little worried.
This guy's up there at all the
forces of down. So we got ask.
So what does that mean?
Well,
I have to agree that all down I see t
plus m g is the downward force that's
gotta be MV squared over r
better four t is equal to m g
minus B squared over r minus g.
So what does that mean?
This d comes out negative.
You're dead good.
If it's negative,
you want the track to exert an upward
force and it can act in the real amusement
park. They have other t brackets
and so on to support you.
What do you really believe in laws of
physics. You don't need any of that.
You just got to make sure this number
is positive for it to be positive.
You need B squared bigger
than or equal to RG.
So you've got to make sure the veneer on
the top, you have this minimum velocity.
If you go faster than that, that is
just fine. You go faster than that.
Tb would a positive number.
So here's the interesting thing.
Have he escaped the pull of gravity?
How come we are not falling down
and the track is not helping us?
It's also pushing us down.
Yes.
Uh,
the tool and forth and changing the
direction of the velocity. But uh,
yes.
So the point is if you have
an apple with two forces,
both pushing down that
apple is accelerating down
and accelerating down means
really falling towards the ground two
at the center of the circle here in this
example,
it is definitely accelerating,
but acceleration is not
added to zero velocity,
in which case it'll pick up more and more.
Speed is added to a huge
horizontal velocity in a tiny time.
You give it a little velocity like this,
your new velocity points at a new angle.
That just means your body has come
here and it's stop going like that and
started going like this.
Therefore,
downward acceleration does not
mean coming closer to the ground.
It only means you velocity vector is
changing its direction. On the other hand,
if you had no velocity vector downward
accelerations mean what you think it is.
That is why if you drop an apple from
here, it is an acceleration due to mg.
If the track was pushing
it down even more,
it'll fall towards the
ground and hit the ground.
But here it's actually
has an acceleration,
but doesn't mean you're
any closer to the center.
Going around in a circle as an example
of constantly accelerating toward the
center,
but not getting any closer.
That's the way back to his work
and you should think about that.